there just really isn't a lot of
compromise so I just thought if I'm
gonna do this job this way I just have
to 100% not care what anybody thinks but
really not care what the left thinks but
what I have in return is so much better
because I think that I feel gratitude
and the fact that I can represent so
many people who are voiceless in the
mainstream media hey hey and welcome
this is the Ben Shapiro show Sunday
special I am supremely excited to
welcome to the show co-host of the view
Megan McCain we're gonna get to know
Megan in just a moment but first you
should have life insurance why because
if you don't you should be scared why
should you be scared well if your plots
your family is basically in a lot of
trouble but more people are afraid for
the prospect of trying to get life
insurance than actually getting life
insurance if the idea of looking for
life insurance intimidates you try
policy genius.com
policy genius is the easy way to shop
for life insurance online in minutes you
can compare quotes from top insurers and
find your best price and policy genius
doesn't just make life insurance easy
they can also help you find the right
home insurance ordinal insurance
disability insurance they're your
one-stop-shop for insurance shopping
policy genius will give you peace of
mind again life insurance it's an adult
thing to do be an adult this October
take the scariness out of buying life
insurance with policy genius go to
policy genius com get quotes apply in
minutes you can do the whole thing on
your phone right now in fact pause what
you're doing go to policy genius calm
your life insurance come back here and
then if God forbid something happens to
you later today you're taking care of
policy genius calm the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance
Megan thanks so much for stopping by I
really appreciate it yeah thank you I
mean I feel like excited and nervous I'm
a fan of your work and we're friends
offline in real life too and I don't
know it's like a new season on the show
and you're my first interview and I'm
like anxious and excited
it'll be fine also I mean people should
know it's we have a kind of funny
relationship because we started off like
really at odds right I was not a fan by
the way my husband has there's a tweet
when we got engaged where someone had
tweeted out I had said something like or
like a publisher or someone that said
like you could win a date with Megan
McCain and he wrote a tweet that said do
not want and when we got
I was like joke's on him we got married
so there was because my husband's very
conservative and at the time it was
running a website called red state and I
remember I actually he was my one of my
books actually my very early but there's
more surprised by the man I ended up
marrying than me like supreme love and
respect I'm deeply in love and he's the
best decision I ever made but he's the
most conservative man I ever met maybe
and tell you so and when we went out the
first time I was like this is a totally
different vibe and it's way better I
tell women conservative men have better
family values and they take dating and
family and marriage more seriously I
mean that is a hundred percent true and
it's one of the things I always I always
say to people who are dating people date
for a whole host of reasons that are
other than values and I'm always saying
to people that is the biggest mistake I
think if you're serious which I was when
I met my husband about getting married
and having kids and wanting to go to the
next phase I just found in my life
dating finally dating a conservative man
was the one so but he took it seriously
I mean when we first went out he was
like oh yeah don't want to I want I want
to get married I when I have kids
ya know those and those are good dates I
mean my first show with my wife we had a
three-hour conversation about freewill
determinism in how many kids we wanted
and three and a half months later we
were engaged and we married for 11 years
so it worked out great so we have to
start with obviously the fact that
you're on the view which is the hardest
job for a conservative in media and I
should know I mean I do a pretty rough
job I get you hired now I mean I talk a
lot and I get clocked a lot but I don't
actually have to discuss politics with
people who virulently disagree each and
every day and be in the minority on a
show where that happens so how do you
deal with the pressure number one of
being the person who has to sort of
carry the torch for carry the flag for
conservatism and and second of all how
do you deal with being in the minority
I'm on the show all the time that's got
to be a difficult dynamic well I mean
there's like a lot of different ways
about it the first thing is that it's a
privilege to because a lot of people
don't know any Republicans or don't know
any conservatives so I'm the voice they
hear when they're tuning into the view
whether they like it or not there's a
diversity of opinion the pressure of it
is that I'm not I'm not a trump ER
obviously and sometimes I feel like I'm
not exactly
right person for the job that maybe they
should have had a full-blown Trump
person in that seat because it's like
sort of more reflective of where the
party's at I'm surprised I have this job
I'm surprised I've lasted this long at
the job and I say that like with respect
but it's a really tough one and this is
now my third year and I had the worst
year of my life between August of 2018
in August of 2019 like I just had a
horrible year my father's cancer there
was a lot of death in my life I've been
open I had a miscarriage and there was
so much coming at me at once I thought
like I don't know if I could continue
doing this and at the same time I feel
like the only Republican in all of
Manhattan and people are quite can be
quite hostile and I'm not a snowflake
I'm not a someone who can't handle
pressure and anger and reaction but
sometimes I feel like I really have to
get out of the bubble like I really have
to leave Manhattan or do you see
otherwise I'm gonna go crazy and then I
think as you know when you go to the
middle of the country I was just in
Wyoming people are like give him a leg
and it's it feels extremely rewarding
and as cheesy as it sounds when I was in
college I used to watch Elisabeth
Hasselbeck on the view and I was like
yes and I remember her fight about the
Iraq war with Rosie O'Donnell and I
remember being like that's exactly what
she should be saying that's exactly why
are they talking to her like that and I
hope there's like this sounds very
cheesy but there's like a teenage girl
someplace that thinks that about me I
mean I'm not a teenage Vil and I think
that every time I watch the view lately
because there there's somebody who's
actually making good arguments and the
amount of abuse that you take is truly
astonishing and people putting it on the
cover of magazines and and the stories
of what's going on it you're working all
of this and I have to say I think that
you've really handled it with a lot of
class have you built a bubble around
yourself to protect yourself I know
that's that's what I've had to do right
I just had to operate at a remove it's
it's difficult because I want to be on
Twitter all the time but I've had to not
because it's just too much have you been
able to sort of handle all the blowback
well the abuse is from the media it's
not internally so that I think it's for
whatever reason my presence is very
triggering to a lot of people and just
who I am and I I know you can understand
this as well but there's something about
being in a mainstream Network and you
have an obviously a mainstream show as
well as a conservative who didn't go
native I'm not trying to placate the
left I'm not trying to placate Democrats
I'm not trying to become a
accepted in liberal media circles and I
think there's something about that that
has brought out like anger and people
for some reason and it's a combination
of things when my dad died my world got
much more insular because I just don't
want to open up to as many people my
husband has been the most incredible I
hope every woman has the kind of husband
I have and I say that as someone who
dated like every bull in West Hollywood
possible before I met my husband so if I
could say that on your show I hope I can
swear but a really amazing supportive
group of friends I have an incredible
husband I have a really great family I'm
really lucky I have a great relationship
with my brothers and my sisters my mom
and I have honestly like people like you
people like Dina lash people like SE
Cupp who are also the few conservatives
in mainstream media that I have built a
relationship with it I mean I have
called you at times where I'm like I
don't know if I can do this anymore
what what am i doing it was this okay
and I called Dana lash and her husband
sometimes and we like you know I'm like
am I the only person that thinks it's
okay to still have an NRA ar-15 like and
then you know you're reminded that there
are other people doing this and then I'm
also reminded that there are people that
you know go into mines and fight in Iraq
all day and getting my hair and makeup
done and getting in a fight which really
isn't the worst thing in the entire
world so I want to talk a little bit
about how you got to this point because
you have a really kind of interesting
political yeah it is very weird
political yeah so let's start from the
very beginning what was it like growing
up with John McCain as a dad because
that's got to be pretty intense um you
know he was he's you know he's become
this like obviously especially since his
passing he's been come like such an
iconic figure for so many people and he
was the best dad and I don't just say
that because I'm on camera and because
he's now no longer here but he just let
me be exactly who I was which was like
wild and crazy and very loud and all
these things that they don't know if a
man of his generation would
traditionally like let his daughter
become which is why I think I'm so tough
right now and he just really made space
for me every time I called he would
answer when he was in DC I would come
home on the weekends we would go hiking
and fishing and you know hike in Arizona
and I have like the most beautiful
memories
then when he ran for office I was always
involved in his campaigns even when I
was very very young and I was always
interested in always curious I would
always go with him to his interviews
when he ran for president the second
time I left call it like graduate
college and then joined his campaign and
I miss him it's it's unbelievable how
much you can miss someone like their
daily on my way here I was like he'd be
so entertained I'm doing her show you
know like there are things that I still
just want to share and get his feedback
on and you know it's the I still have
this like big hole in my heart that I'm
trying to just keep pushing on and grief
is just it all just up and it is
omnipresent and they'd this what they
say about the first year I have found
true I know not everyone's experience is
the same but getting through the first
year I feel a little better now like not
a lot but there's this like okay I got
through a year since he passed and so
now I can just a very long wooden answer
to your question but I feel I feel his
absence all the time but I don't feel
quite as anxious about it as I did well
what was it like working on his
campaigns cuz that's that's got to be
different I mean by working I had a blog
that is very embarrassing
McCain vlog at which was very cute and
very sort of saccharine and sweet at the
time it was like a blog about being on
the campaign with my dad and I was very
young I was 22 to 24 when he ran for
president and I wasn't taken seriously
at all
and I just had last I mean I was like
hanging out going to rallies it was a
very innocent and beautiful and
optimistic time in my life because he
obviously became the nominee and I got
to see all the beautiful parts of
politics like how he inspired people how
much American can come together for
different things and that election on
his end was so classy in so many
different ways and he never got I was so
funny I was talking about this with my
friends in the car on the way over here
he like never got in the dirt with
people he never he didn't obviously do
all the things that Trump now does and
yeah it bred my love and interest in
politics too I mean on that note do you
think that maybe it was a mistake for
him not to meaning that it sort of set
the precedent for Republicans going okay
well if John McCain had only fought
harder than he would have won in 2000
and then we'd sort of did the same thing
in 2012
Romney had only fought harder and then
Trump was like I will throw this bathtub
at someone and really yeah so I think
it's a choice you make obviously and
obviously it worked very well for Trump
and it didn't work for Romney and it
didn't work for my dad but I will say
that he and when he ran for wasn't the
first time in the year 2000 he had said
it was okay that he thought the
Confederate flag should be flown at the
South Carolina Capitol and up until like
weeks before he died he still felt
guilty about it and felt like it was the
wrong decision and the kind of man he
was
he was so riddled with I don't know if
it was like the military guilt that he
grew up with in the sense that like
character was so important but every
decision he thought was a mistake he
just held on to and he would apologize
and if you ever watch his HBO
documentary he's very candid about it
and I think that he wouldn't have been
able to live with himself and certainly
like die in the way that he did with
such grace and class and no regrets
whatsoever in the sense that like he was
like I did everything my way and I think
had he gone down in the gutter I think
he would have regretted it and he always
said I would rather lose an election
than when the wrong way did he ever talk
to you growing up about his experiences
in Vietnam and what that was like yeah
but it wasn't often and he never wanted
to anyone to feel bad for him
ever under any circumstances but as
weird as this sounds would sometimes
talk about it on Christmas like during
the day I don't know why that was always
like sort of like the time when it felt
okay to talk about but um there were
different stories who would tell that
were I know this I hope this isn't sound
McCobb but almost entertaining like
there hewitt halle stories about like
tapping on the walls between him and his
fellow POWs and but des and all his
friends that he met in prison and then
the story there's a famous story about
his cellmate sewing an American flag in
his jacket and then the prison guards
finding it and beating him and beating
him so badly that he is his I was almost
swollen and then my dad looked over and
he was knitting the American flag again
all over again so with stories like that
that were beautiful as well as very sad
but we would talk about it but not not
terribly often but we would does never
annoy you how the media has sort of
rewritten
treatment of him so now you got the
iPhone li we had a Republican like John
McCain again and in 2008 the order
dumping all over him continuously for a
year I mean I remember because I was
raising money for mitt no way and I just
remember the consistent attacks on his
character I mean I remember folks who
are now anchors at CNN at the time
talking about how he was a racist and
all this sort of stuff and now it seems
sort of in an attempt to draw contrasts
with Trump it's like oh you remember
that that great guy John McCain and how
great he was cuz it doesn't ever annoy
you that it's like well you're saying
all this stuff about him now wouldn't it
have been nice if you had said it about
him then oh yeah and I think that there
I mean he didn't care like he really for
me it's just interesting sometimes to
hear people be like you know your dad
such an amazing person and it's like
it's I don't doubt his legacy I don't
doubt the the newfound love for him that
maybe on the left in the center I found
but I remember people comparing him to
George Wallace I remember prominent
people comparing him to George Wallace
when he was running I remember the
things that were said and I try not to
dwell on it because what's the point but
I do think it's strange that sort of the
media sometimes the only comfortable
Republican is someone who's no longer in
power that like that's the good like
Jeff Flake is an incredible Republican
now but I talked to me you know whatever
four or five years ago when he has to
get a plus rating from every
conservative metric pause possible but
the second he comes out against Trump
now he's the real hero and I would like
there to be a more balanced with the
media when it comes to Republicans who
are currently in power and that the
point is that we're gonna disagree the
point is that where you have different
beliefs and worldviews but there's a lot
of hypocrisy it bothers people in my
life a little more than me like sort of
the reinvention of what 2008 was like
but yeah of course I remember every
single bad thing that I've ever been
said about my dad by anybody and if
anybody around me thinks I forgot or
comes up to me and thinks I haven't
forgotten I assure you I remember so
when it comes to your own politics and
how they were shaped by your dad being
your dad were there any areas of
significant disagreement when you were
growing up with your dad on politics
marriage equality gay marriage when I
was growing up was always like a big
divide between us and you know he was of
a totally different generation and
that's only really a big one
but I sort of took my eye it's so funny
because Abbie Huntsman who's on the show
with me is lovely I always say we're
like kind of miniature our dad's like
she's this very like centrist
diplomat and I'm this sort of like
flamethrower aggressive like pretty
hardcore conservative and it's so funny
it's a good nature versus nurture
argument because so much of my politics
does sort of echo his and definitely has
as I've gotten older but I've also
gotten a lot more conservative in the
Trump years and I don't know if it's
just I feel like so many things have
been illuminated through Trump becoming
president but I see so much hypocrisy
and the way I'm covered and the way the
things I'm said are covered and the way
other conservatives are covered and
sometimes it's like and even when I was
talking about coming on the show with
you I was talking to a friend and it's
like people are angry at you because
you're a powerful conservative and
conservatives in general are going to be
by a certain swath of the media evil bad
ugly crazy but put the nasty name
attached to it and that's how you get
Trump when all of us are evil and nasty
then no one is that's exactly right I
mean that it is astonishing I think the
reason that you come in for so much hit
is because you are actually being
included in the conversation and that's
what's so offensive to people meaning if
you were just speaking your mind and you
weren't at a table with a bunch of
people who disagree and actually just
having conversations and it getting
combative but actually being a
conversation then I don't think you'd be
getting half of the flack that you're
getting meaning that they don't spend an
enormous amount of time in the media
ripping on Rush Limbaugh or really even
Sean Hannity at this point because those
are people who are speaking to a
particular audience they're not debating
with people on the left and the great
fear seems to be for so many people who
are on the hardcore left even allowing a
conservative in the room to have the
conversation and so that's been an issue
you know for booking shows like this one
we reached out to every single
Democratic presidential candidate the
only one who was willing to go on was
Andrew yang I've treated everybody on
the show really well but one has me yeah
one of the big problems is that the hate
and shame that is directed at people for
even being willing to sit down and have
a conversation is extraordinary so to
take an example P boo to judge
originally say
you know that he was willing to come on
the show he got hit so hard online that
he immediately canceled it and said I
won't go on the show anymore and so for
you because you're in it my guess is
that one of the reasons that there's so
much hatred directed at you is because
you are de facto on the stage and there
are a lot of people who'd like to see
not on the stage because it's a
legitimation of a viewpoint that a lot
of people feel is just simply not
legitimate and it's inherently bad it's
inherently wrong and can't be included
as part of the conversation yeah I mean
I think that's true of any prominent
conservative that sort of has to cross
over appealed past and I love a lot of
people on Fox News I don't love
everybody but I love a lot of people on
Fox News and I think when you sort of
like as you've done like exit the
conservative media bubble and you have a
voice elsewhere it becomes very
threatening because you know you could
change a mind possibly one way or
another and it's interesting being this
voice right now because I was not taken
seriously at all for a really long time
and it no one finds it where I think
I've told you before that like no one
finds it more ironic and humorous that
like I'm the great threat to liberal
ideals when I was saying I was like the
Queen Rhino party girl for so long and
people asked like how I got here and a
lot of things I grew up number one I'm
almost 35 35 in a few weeks my politics
shifted as it always does with most
rational people as you get older and
then I saw that as much as I have in the
past wanted to meet in the middle with
people which I still do but I know that
again it doesn't matter how much I meet
in the middle on some things nothing is
going to be perfect enough unless I see
it exactly your way if I say okay let's
have a conversation about background
checks that's not good enough cuz you
want to take the hell your guns away
whatever Beto said that's the level you
bring it to and so I think the good and
part of my life is that I've learned
that there just really isn't a lot of
compromise so I just thought if I'm
gonna do this job this way I just have
to 100% not care what anybody thinks but
really not care what the left thinks and
every fun party I've ever been invited
to is gone every interesting you know
like social experience I ever had over
but what I have in return
is so much better because I think that I
feel gratitude and the fact that I can
represent so many people who are
voiceless in the mainstream media okay
so let's talk about your sort of
political evolution so you referred to
it a little bit earlier and I know that
from abroad I watched as it seemed like
you got more conservative but in what
areas do you think that you've got more
conservative I mean there's so many I
guess you'd have to like sort of pick
the subject but I think I just feel like
the way government is run in a in the
way that the Republican Party feels like
limited government in small government
is by far a better and more efficient
way for the government to be run on a
social aspect it's so funny I believe in
the family unit and the importance of
having children and the importance of a
two-parent household in a way and I
don't mean that in a negative way
towards single parents but I just it's
been interesting as you get older I sort
of came up to all the cliches that
people do is they say I think if you're
young and you're not liberal you don't
have a heart and if you're old and
conserve you don't have a brain I never
had a heart and I think just being
bullied so much by people sort of turn I
was like you nothing I ever do will ever
be good enough ever enough no fight I
fight will ever be good enough and I
just feel a lot of hypocrisy and how
things are covered and and which people
get on TV for what reason like Michael
have not he's a really great example and
it doesn't matter if he hates me and
hate tweets at me all the time but I
remember being like this person does not
deserve a platform I think he's taking
advantage of this woman of stormy
Daniels I don't understand why he's
getting the kind of platform and
attention he has the only reason why he
has this kind of platform and attention
is because he hates drop and that
doesn't seem completely ethical to me
so it's seeing a lot of hypocrisy in the
media as well and also the fact that I
didn't go totally psycho and ever Trump
that I still just try and see both sides
has really angered a lot of people and
by the way I have the best reason of all
of you to go psycho never Trump and I
just try and dafair and balance its
cliches that sounds in the way that I
take on an analyze every issue and that
made me more conservative like people
are very angry that I have not turned
into someone who just can't say you know
screw trump he's a maniac every five
seconds but I don't think that's fair or
valid to his supporters to the viewers
of the view and to Republicans who
struggle with this president in so many
different ways cuz I know I do that does
bring us to the elephant that's always
in the room revenue which is president
trumping and he's been difficult for
everybody on the conservative side of
the aisle to deal with to you was that
has he ever attacked you um no I have
studiously avoided being with
range of his eye so I sort of view
president from like the Eye of Sauron as
long as I'm outside of it I'm okay and
if ever I'm focused in on by the Eye of
Sauron then then he demands absolute
fealty and bow before Trump but in all
of this kind of stuff so instead I've
just sort of avoided him frankly but
obviously I'm not in your position so
that's a that's a very different thing
obviously I came under fire from a lot
of his allies in 2016 because I took a
view that I was not going to vote for
either of the main candidates I didn't
think he'd ever met my standard for
being president but obviously you have
been attacked by by President Trump your
dad obviously was was attacked by
President Trump is one of the things
that drove me away from voting for him
in 2016 so what's been your view of
Trump and evolution of your view on
Trump it's it's hard because I try and
take it issue it by issue every day and
there are some decisions he's made that
I agree with and I think it's fine there
are other decisions and things he
doesn't says that I think are just
absolutely insane on every single
plausible level but I could never come
to him because I still believe character
matters I still believe that decency and
ethics matter and the way he lives his
life and conducts himself in the things
he says not only about my family but
about so many others it's just not what
I want for the leader of the free world
and I am ferociously protective of my
father and his legacy in like an animal
and I will never forgive it ever as long
as I don't care what other people have
done I don't care how other people have
moved on I will never be able to ever
and he continues to do it since he has
passed which is just monstrous
and horrific and deeply painful to my
family and he doesn't care which makes
it even weirder I mean that must make it
pretty difficult for you to be as
objective as you are and I mean you
started by talking about the policies
that you like versus the the stuff that
you don't like and on a softer level I
mean I can say that I've said publicly
and my opinion of president Trump's
character has never changed one iota
from the time that he came on the public
stage in 2015 and came down to the
magical escalator and all of that the
only thing that's changed my view of him
at all is that I thought he was not
going to govern conservatively and
actually he has governed fairly
conservatively in a variety of areas
moving forward to 2020 Mike
I'm voting for him has shifted for two
reasons one is because the status quo
that was not avoided in 2016 was not
avoided in 2016
meaning that this is the new reality and
now it's like Trump is what Trump is I'm
not sure he's making things worse
because frankly I'm not sure how he
could I mean we all have baked it into
the cake and the question then becomes
really sort of binary it's the reality
of Trump versus the reality of whatever
Democrat is up for it that's that sort
of point number one and then point
number two is that you know he is the
damage that I had hope to avoid by not
voting for him has either been incurred
or it has not been incurred and he is
governed more conservatively than I
thought he would so that that sort of
alleviated my fears on political level
it found a character level it didn't I
assume you're not going to vote for him
in 2020 what's what's your sort of math
on on 2020 I mean right now I think
everyone wants to see if it's gonna be
Biden or as hyper progressive Warren or
Sanders born in Sanders it's all too
much for me it's just it's I mean and
I've just that's the simplest way I can
put it I don't believe in democratic
socialism so many of their policies I
think are dangerous and could lead us
down a path that much like Trump we
wouldn't not in a different way we
couldn't necessarily come back from I I
could never vote for President Trump for
all the personal reasons and for me it's
just it's just too much it hurts my
heart and if he could have just been a
decent human being and not and you know
not said so many incendiary things I
think I think I'm actually like the beta
test example of a conservative woman
who's just been so turned off by his
behavior and his you know for everything
is the way he actually talks way he
treats his wife etc that I think I'm the
example of a woman who just can't come
to terms with it but you know it that's
their problem that's his problem that
he's turned off people like me for so
many reasons and when it comes to
Democrats I just hope I hope that biden
ends up running as the man I know him to
be and is you know the sort of classic
Democrat that he was for a lot I mean I
don't know who senator Biden from yeah
other than what I see from him so what
what is Senator Biden like I mean is he
kind of manipulative politician or is he
genuine what what it
what is he like I'm the wrong girl to
ask because I love him I mean I'm like
really the wrong person like I fully say
on the show too as well which is also by
the way why I don't know if I'm always
the best Republican on the show because
I have this personal relationship with
him and I think as you know when people
become people it's it's hard to dislike
them and he really could his son Beau
died of the same cancer glioblastoma
that my dad did so when I was going
through the process I'm someone who
really wants like facts and I want to
know what things are gonna look like and
feel like and I don't like surprises and
doctors who are incredible and my father
had like the greatest doctors medical
care can find and I'm very grateful to
them but doctors need to be optimistic
and there are times when I just wanted
to know what's the bad part and I would
call him and say what's this gonna look
like what's this gonna feel like what
does it mean when another tumor grows
what does it mean when it's in the
frontal lobe what is you know what is it
gonna look like what is palliative care
I don't know what that means what's the
difference between a hospice and
palliative care and he would pick up the
phone and coach me through it and I have
cried on the phone to that man
more times than I'm sure he knew what he
was getting into when we originally
originally he was friends with my dad
when I was growing up but we originally
really reconnected on the show of all
things and it was not last November but
the November before and my dad was in
the hospital at Walter Reed and he had
had another he had pneumonia he had had
another tumor grow I don't remember and
I was just a mess I probably shouldn't
have gone on air that day but after the
show I was gonna go back to DC and he
was there and I just lost it on air and
you can google it went viral and he
really it coached me through it and was
just so incredibly lovely and nurturing
and in the same way that Trump being
such a vicious bull to my family clouds
my judgment the love that Senator I call
him job um gave to me clouds any opinion
I have of him and I love him very much
and I think he has a wonderful family
and I call him the grief whisperer
he understands grief and pain in a way
that I've never met anybody else like it
so why do you think so many Democrats
are viciously attacked I don't get it
frankly I mean even for somebody who
doesn't know him and I've been critical
of Vice President Biden you know I
very critical of him particularly on
policy grounds but I don't see the
attack really like he seems like
everybody I've talked to you from Ted
Cruz to you has said the Joe Biden is a
nice guy
that he's a decent person and yet he's
getting hit with he's a racist then he's
a bigot that he's so old that he can't
hold it together now frankly I think the
fact that he's older is gonna help him
in a general election because he's
really unthreatening I mean his a his
the whole kind of dynamic of
unthreatening older fellow who is not
Elizabeth Warren and doesn't want to
destroy the economy versus volatile
Donald Trump I think actually cuts in
Joe Biden's favor but the the attacks on
him have been extraordinary I thought
very unkind very unkind and I hate
ageism in general because again like I
my dad was up until he got sick he was
81 when he almost 81 means I'd like a
few days away from being anyone and he
was you know hiking the Grand Canyon and
working like crazy so I don't
necessarily like buy into just because
her old you can't do your job well but I
think the attacks are I when hooli and
Castro was making fun of Joe Biden's
Asian last debate I thought I was gonna
throw my computer across the room and
out the window I was so mad that wasn't
a fair hit ready to attack him on edge
you got to do any Ashley gasps he can't
he's not gaffing I mean I tweeted enough
that's enough Paulie and that is enough
it's just so reductive but I I'm very
worried I'm very concerned about it
because I don't think it deserves it and
B I think Democrats cannibalize
themselves and they're gonna eat their
own and if you want purity and you want
this progressive ideal that I know I'm
being told everyday by a lot of people
that Elizabeth Warren can win over the
middle of the country I'm not sold on it
and I've interviewed her I think twice
I'm not sold yet because I should be
more won over by some of the like folksy
stories and things like that and I'm
really not at all and I think a lot of
the stuff she's saying is just Bernie
Sanders but in a different I mean person
I think she's a fake and the reason I
think she's fake is because when in 2003
when I was going to Harvard Law School
she was a recruiter for Harvard Law and
I met her at at the top of the W Hotel
and she proceeded to say some things
about Rush Limbaugh with which I
disagreed but she was actually an
interesting person in 2003-2004 when she
supported school choice she talked
not remaking the entire American economy
she talked about she was a Republican
once upon a time I mean a long time ago
she's Republican but even as late as the
the early 2000s when she was getting all
sorts of attention because she had
written this book about bankruptcy a lot
of her policies were based in the idea
that the that's what she called the to
income trap the idea that maybe women in
the workplace had actually created
certain obstacles for families moving
forward that wasn't a case for women not
being in the workplace but it did create
obstacles including rising rising prices
in the suburbs failing schools had
pushed people out to the suburbs
competition for price it's really
interesting stuff or book to income trap
is really fascinating her numbers are
rising I mean I his aren't following
hers are rising I don't know what that
ultimately means but I know that I mean
it's so radical it's so far from where
the Democratic Party was even you know
three years ago and if she's the future
I really don't know where the hell
independence in this country are left
because I know a lot of people a lot of
people in my life will secretly vote for
Trump over this they're not gonna tell
you because they don't want to be
ashamed about it I have so many friends
who will call me and they're saying
they're making me vote for Trump and
it's never like I want to vote for Trump
it's always they're making me because I
have a lot of friends who are sort of
holdouts in 2016 and then they'll look
at the Democratic Party and they'll say
to themselves
no way I have no choice like they like
it's what what is what from says it is
rallies where he's like you may not like
me but you have no choice
well when I'm looking at the radical
Democrats I don't feel like I have tons
of choice and I wonder what happened to
the Democratic Party and who is
responsible for this because and it's
like did Trump do it did Trump create
this like sort of like yin to the yang
and in it I don't really know how it got
displaced did Bernie just unleash this
dragon that took hold that has taken
over in so many spaces I don't know the
answer but I do think that's the future
and I think it's very scary yeah I mean
you've talked about this on the shotgun
just shall ask for it but when you talk
about the intersectional ism of the
Democratic Party
it is pretty frightening and and the
entire left has now bought into this now
and should say the entire left a large
segment of left has bought into this
including virtue signaling about
intersectionality and bizarre and
strange ways it's one of the reasons why
you know to go back to Biden for a
moment when I when I look at Biden and
Biden makes a speech in which he talks
about the the original vision of the
country and I was trying to fulfill that
I think that's
in line with just kind of traditional
American politics and then you get beta
on on stage talking about how America is
founded on slavery and rooted in slavery
and how we have to all acknowledge that
every inequality in American life is
rooted in slavery and I think to myself
I don't know what happened to these
people I mean I really don't well Biden
also says like not every Republican as a
bad person I know plenty of good
Republican friends and he's just been
you know taking so much heat for even
silly statements like that like I don't
understand why that's offensive to
people mayor Pete has really
disappointed me when I first when you
first came on the view I was like this
is a guy from the Midwest who really
gets America who really gets like the
middle of the country could probably win
over all these Rust Belt voters that
Hillary ended up losing and then for me
his his take on abortion is so extreme
and so out of the realm of where I think
most Americans even if you're pro-choice
are he gave an interview where he was
talking about his interpretation of the
Bible maybe could be birth doesn't begin
until a baby's born and I'm paraphrasing
what he said like breath did you see
that interview and I don't know where
that's coming from I mean not the Bible
I'm as it turns out I'm very very
well-versed in the Bible like in the
original Hebrew and no it is our
statement like who are you winning over
with that because they don't already
have so many supporters on the left you
need to win over me right and that makes
me run screaming in the other I don't
know what his pitches I mean originally
when he emerged on the stage like this
guy's interesting he's interesting right
he seems like he treats people like
human beings he was saying the whole as
soon as he said I'm willing to eat a
chick-fil-a they've got good chicken I
was like oh a rational sane human being
and so what he's gay like who cares yeah
it's very warm and likeable and he was
when he first came on I was I was like
oh my god like what a great like what a
refreshing Democrat I mean I said at the
very beginning I thought that he was he
was really fascinating I said it on air
and then he got into this whole pastor
Pete routine and he's quieting the Bible
more frequently than I do and I don't do
it all that often but I just kept
thinking to myself why are we getting
Bible class with with B booty drives
like why why why does he think that it's
a smart strategy to tell every Christian
in the country that they're
misinterpreting the Bible
and that abortion on demand is
biblically mandated I don't see the
strategy there it's bizarre and I don't
know if it's just sort of the temptation
to go very progressive during because
that's what you think you need to win
during primaries and maybe he just
wasn't thinking about the general but
he's the one in particular not to like
you know spend so much time trashing him
because they don't I still think he's
probably a good and decent person but I
think his politics are much different
than I had originally I mean it
definitely raises the the more general
question and of social media itself so
you've been engaged and not so engaged
and engaged in social media I'm so
addicted that it's like it's like just
like I'm so addicted to social media I
have to get off it but it is the worst
place on earth I mean I it's a cesspool
I thank God for me that four years
between Friday night and Saturday night
I was off at right like just technically
mandated Thank You Bible and I couldn't
be on Twitter and then I would come back
on Saturday night and my life would be
ruined and then for six days would suck
and then I'd have another day what was
great and recently I realized I don't
have to be on this thing and I don't
actually miss out on all that money to
do that because social media it used to
be I feel like the nature of social
media changed I feel like back even in
2008-2009 when you and I were going at
it on social media it was like okay fine
this is just sort of a game like we go
at it like maybe it's not it's just kind
of silly like it was too silly was like
a chatroom when you were 17 and people
are asking age sex location like it was
yeah this is like a completely different
thing and and now it's we have to be
super serious we have to treat every
tweet as though it is a presidential
proclamation and and and we are going to
go back and treat the old tweets when
you were just joking in 2007 as though
that was a presidential proclamation and
we're just gonna cancel everybody so
what's what's your advice for dealing
with the canceled culture since you've
been subjected to it several times I
can't believe I haven't been canceled I
mean it I go in every day of my job
assuming I'm gonna get fired for
something I say and that's not
reflective of ABC or the view it's just
reflective of the times we're living in
like I don't even keep like I keep just
enough clothes in my closet that I could
take it in a bag to go every time
because some of the things sometimes I
say things where I'm like and I I'm
actually pretty insulated I'm pretty
surrounded by mostly conservatives at
this point just because socially it's a
little easier
and I just don't want to be virtue
signal that in my free time but I can't
believe I am on mainstream media with
being as conservative as I am and I'm
you know as you said you're like
compared to you you're a moderate you
know and I the good news is you're gonna
get some strange new respect after this
interview because because you're sitting
next to me this means that you are now
back in moderate territory right exactly
it'll be it'll be perfect and then
you'll go back on the view and I'll
realize you're conservative and then
you're in trouble again
so enjoy the two hours between when this
episode airs it's interesting because
when I told some people I was coming on
here it's like people have I'm drawn to
people who get the same reactions I do
where they're like and he's incredible
like I listen to him every day I guess
like whatever and then oh my god that
guy what you know and I think people
have that reaction to me where they're
like you know you're either like the
voice of reason or you're a psychopath
maniac that's destroying everything but
I literally think I could be canceled on
any day because there are things that I
think and I'm like oh we all think that
and then I go on TV and I'm like oh
apparently that's a good an extremely
controversial thing to say and by the
time I get home I'm like I don't
understand why what I said is so
controversial at all because things that
10 minutes ago weren't controversial are
really controversial now and so and I'm
not good at censoring myself or staying
on script or anything that like I think
traditional hosts have to do in a lot of
ways so I've only used at the left it
the left isn't either I mean because the
line is so constantly shifting people
who are woke one minute are completely
unmoved the next I mean yeah that is
what's happening to to Biden is that he
was hewn to all of the traditional
standards and then the line just
radically moved and suddenly he was on
the other side of the line according to
this group and you see it happened to
would you don't like full-on leftist and
all the sudden the line moves and I find
myself defending Sara's wrong it over at
the New York Times and it's like how did
we end up on the same side of the page
this is bizarre so have you I mean you
have your own they I guess the beauty of
your job is that you have your you own
your own work yeah but I mean I do
wonder how many people will be left at a
certain point yeah I mean it's it's one
of the reasons why subscribing to two
independent stuff is important because
you can see the pressure that's being
brought to bear on corporations and
being brought to bear on advertiser
I mean earlier this year we had this
bizarre stupid situation in which I was
speaking at the March for Life and this
is of course very controversial and I
made the what I thought was completely
an arguable comment that you should not
kill babies before they're born based on
the possibility that those babies might
grow up to commit crimes right the
freakanomics argument that well abortion
was responsible for dropping crime rates
and like well you don't get to kill
children because they might commit a
crime later and I said you know as a
pro-lifer even if there were baby Hitler
unborn I wouldn't kill that baby I would
adopt the kidnap I said the phrase baby
Hitler it trended number-one on Twitter
we called the advertisers like we just
need you you can cancel like we're not
gonna stop you but we need you to
explain what was actually morally wrong
about that Lake was I it was I supposed
to kill free nascent baby your answer
their answer was it that they got 20
tweets and they and they cancelled the
advertising and so that that
unfortunately is the way that it seems
to are so you've taken very strong
pro-life positions it's been what makes
people the craziest of all the issues
this and guns are the ones that make
people that's where the most hate comes
from perfect see just at the agenda for
the next three minutes okay so well
let's talk about the the pro-life
positions were you always this pro-life
I was the media just never paid as much
attention it's so funny it's like a
chicken or the egg concept and actually
on my first date with my husband it was
one of the questions he asked me he was
very surprised that I was pro-life and I
was like a few drinks in and I was like
I think abortion is abhorrent and I
could never do it and you know I don't
understand you know the conversations
that are being had right now and he was
very surprised and then when I got on
the view I think it was just that and
this is no shade to anyone who's sat in
my chair before me because it's a very
hard job but I think a lot of women that
sat in that chair before me were like
well I think that you should make your
own choice but the government shouldn't
regulate it and I was like I think
abortion is murder I'm pro-life I'm not
gonna get on board with any of this and
I think people were like whoa holy Sh
okay that's a different perspective and
it's very very important to me and I
think it's I don't fit the narrative of
a pro-life woman in media like I think
you know I live in Manhattan I don't
have children yet myself you know I work
on network television like I don't know
for whatever reason not appropriately
religious no
yeahyou your prosím sex marriage you
don't fit the sort of stereotype of your
religious soccer mom from Kansas who is
pro-life you're an urban woman who grew
up in media who's pro-life now that is a
unique background for sure we'll get
very like I'll go sometimes like to
restaurants or whatever and pro-life
women will tell me and secret like
they'll come up to me and be like I
thank you for there it makes me sad that
so many people feel like they can't they
have to censor themselves so severely in
the city and I Love New York I'm not
gonna like it all over it but it makes
me sad that there are people they don't
feel comfortable even talking about it
and there's a lot of people in my life
that just don't want to hear it from the
other side they just don't want to be
abused because they have a different
opinion and and and by the way I'm like
a total you know heretic to my gender
because of the way I feel how does it
how does that feel let me be what
anybody thinks of me anymore my you know
I've been through so much last year and
in my life and I've seen so much and
felt so much there is something
liberating about being almost 35 and
going through so many things and and let
me like put a little context last year
between August of 2018 and August of
2019 my father passed away from terminal
brain cancer a employee of my husband's
who was a friend of both of ours an
incredible up-and-coming talent brie
Payton who I'm sure you know passed away
in a freak Rhea freak virus a few months
later our dog our family dog died in a
pipe accident and then I got pregnant
not like surprisingly I was not we were
not planning and then found out I was
having a miscarriage soon after all the
while being trashed in the media I was
pregnant when I went on Seth Meyers and
so the experience of last year I was
like what else can happen to me like
what else so I don't care anymore what
people think to me think about me
because some of the worst things I could
have ever thought happened and I'm not I
don't want to sympathy and I don't want
anyone to cry me a river' and I don't
need like a tiny violin but I
experienced a lot of tragedy last year
and so coming out the other side of it
nothing really impacts me anymore so if
you're mad that I'm pro-life and you're
mad at like you know I don't feel the
same way you feel about socialism I
don't care
bring it I mean it's so small
on the scale of life events for me so I
want to talk to you about something that
you did this last year that that really
did not get the outside attention to
deserve so I thought it was a really
brave and humane thing to do and that
was you talked openly about your
miscarriage so so most women have
miscarriages seem to be you know
embarrassed about it or at least don't
want to talk about it publicly for
whatever reason for reasons of privacy
because it's an element of grief but you
were you're brave and I thought it was a
brave and wonderful thing I mean we
talked about it beforehand obviously for
you to for you to write that op-ed yeah
thank you again for being and again I
hope it's like that weird but you really
have been such an incredible source of
support for me and my career and
recently and it's there are good people
in this industry that will be friends
yeah I think this industry gets a bad
rap that we all like hate each other and
are so competitive but there are really
good people or that will support you
when you need it oh thank you I
appreciate it but it's a beautiful piece
I mean really about what what being
pregnant meant to you and I was
wondering if you could talk about that
for people who may have missed the piece
like what what what that experience was
like and how it changed or deepened your
your beliefs on the pro-life issue well
I know not all women like every woman's
pregnancy and feelings about their body
are different but for me I knew I was
pregnant where something was going on
because I got sick really quickly and I
just like I don't want to get into
graphic detail but like my body I was
like I'm definitely pregnant and I felt
really pregnant and I was really having
a hard time on air on the view and then
on Seth Meyers like I think I probably
would have done a better job but I not
been pregnant because I was just not
feeling well and I was we were gonna get
into that but that was not your fault
he's a no anyway I could have I would
have been sharper like the way we are
now if I wasn't so sick and I just you
know I was sort of getting as dumb as it
sounds I'm married and I'm almost 35 but
it's still you find out you're pregnant
it's it's an intense thing and I
motherhood isn't something that I really
had thought about until I married Benton
cuz I didn't know if I was ever gonna
find somebody I want to get married to
so I don't I was pregnant and then right
before this New York Times photo shoot
that the view did I got a call from my
doctor which I was assuming was just her
telling me my blood work was fine
because I'm tough and nothing bad
happens to me it like never even
occurred to me that I could have a
miscarriage
because I'm made of steel and she told
me like you know there this blood work
isn't looking good and you know you're
more than likely gonna have a
miscarriage and I was like but no like
I'm the toughest check ever like that's
not what's gonna happen and then
obviously I did and I just felt like
there's so many people in media who
struggle with fertility have
miscarriages and had reached out to me
but don't talk about it publicly and I
get it like I get it's hard I was very
ashamed I felt like I did something
wrong I felt like I have too stressful
of a life I have too stressful a job so
many people hate me I didn't do the
right things you should do when you're
pregnant in the beginning like I don't
know I was like should I have taken more
vitamins should I have whatever should
I've slept more and I really blame
myself like I was like this is my fault
and I felt so much shame and I felt like
if I can go on TV and talk about grief
if I can eulogize my dad in front of
like billions of people and I can talk
about this and I just wanted to feel
less alone and so I decided to write
about it because I knew there would be
other women who would feel less alone
and there's something about television
and particularly daytime television that
kind of the only stories you tend to
hear or like I'm pregnant
amazing it was so easy nothing bad ever
happens and there's nothing wrong
without it I wish that for everyone it
just is not my story and I'm you know I
what's the point of having a platform if
you're not gonna talk about things that
are hard it was an amazing thing because
it really was because it again there are
a lot of women who have gone through
this and come out the other side and and
have beautiful healthy children and not
only that it really I mean you talked a
lot in the context of your connection
with your unborn child even as early as
that and I think that's really important
like I thought I've stated yeah I was
absolutely - I felt like I mean it was
grief it was like the inverse of the
grief of my dad it was like all the hope
you have and you know I did all the
things you weren't supposed to do like
Ben and I were like this room could be
the nursery I bought all the baby books
it's impossible not to me yeah I was
like looking up like eternity clothes
that are stylish and like I I did all
the things are not supposed to do and
then I was really embarrassed like I
remember like I have wonderful friends
but they like are
when i text Adem being like there's
gonna I think the doctor thinks there's
gonna be a problem they went to my
apartment and like returned the
maternity clothes I had bought and like
hid them attorney books and I remember
being like I have amazing people in my
life because obviously I don't want to
go home and see that but then I was like
but I wanted to read that book and you
know I had acclimated myself at the idea
of becoming a mother and now I'm just
trying to figure it out because I want I
need God to guide me a little bit right
now classy as I've told you you should
thank you for everything you should do
it you'll be a great mom and Ben will be
a great dad and you still really do it
my husband's the best throughout all of
it though like I have to say without his
foundation of faith and he's deeply
religious I'm religious but my husband
and his family are Anglican and they
they have an amazing foundation of faith
that I have really needed and clung
clung to in the past year and a half of
my life and I'm I believe in God for a
lot of different reasons but Ben was
100% the right man for me through my
life right now and the amount of tragedy
I've had to go through because it's just
like study as a rock and he believes in
God's plan and he's he just always
reminds me that we aren't in control he
is and I'm a control freak and I'm
always like but you know and I I just I
know it sounds probably saccharine for
your show but I really do think God
brought him to me for a reason for a
second let's let's talk about sort of
your religious beliefs oh you don't
really talk about that very much and and
for most of your career you were
perceived as at least early career sort
of as I said before sort of urbane in
the entertainment media your dad wasn't
super overtly religious and so I have no
idea what your religious kind of
affiliation was your religious beliefs
are so where are you religiously I was
raised Baptist and I would still
consider myself Baptist although like
I'd go to my husband's family's Church
when we go to church I don't go every
single Sunday some I go back and forth
between here and DC and sometimes I just
can't do it
I don't adhere to every letter of the
law in the Bible and this is going to
sound maybe a little strange but I find
that I feel God in my faith and most in
nature and my dad was the same way like
in the deserts in Arizona at the Grand
Canyon our ranch a few ever see pictures
I mean it's like on a creek
it's in a canyon it's just absolutely
stunning and over the break when I was
on hiatus we my husband I went to
Wyoming and I was not I just wasn't in a
good place obviously there was a lot of
drama with my show and you know a lot of
terrible rumors everywhere about me and
I had just gone through miscarriage and
I was like I woke up super early in the
morning and I was like I really need a
sign I really need a sign from something
and my husband I went fishing and we saw
a moose in the wild like the distance
between here and like where that green
screen is right there and our fishing
guide was like I've never seen this in
the entire time I've been doing this
about eight years this is crazy and I
was like are we gonna die like I know
they're really dangerous and I took a
video of it and it was I felt like how
could that's the most obvious example of
why I'm a woman of faith I asked God to
send me a sign and then like there's and
I know that it's not always that simple
but like there are reminders if you're
looking for them and I have always been
religious but I find that I'm being
married to a man who can quote my
husband was home-schooled and so he can
quote scripture like off the top of his
head and being married to a man who can
do that has also deepened our faith and
just when my I thought when my dad was
originally diagnosed the first thing Ben
did was like he was like we have to pray
together now and I think he has also
strengthened he's he's been such an
amazing influence on me in so many
different ways and my relationship with
God Ben has definitely helped strengthen
but I'm not a unlike mayor Pete I don't
think that I have all the answers but I
do believe in heaven and an afterlife
and I you know believe in all the normal
things that everyone believes from the
Bible and my dad was always fond of
saying that you know in in Orthodox
duties and the other sort of term that
people don't use so much is used in sort
of the Jewish community as observant
Judaism my dad was always fond of saying
that being an observant Jew doesn't mean
just that you observe the principles it
means if you observe God in the world
around you then you're doing your job as
an observant religious person and so
that sounds sort of like what what
you're talking about as far as sort of
observing everything can either be a
coincidence or it could just be proof of
a plan and it's up to you how to how to
interpret all of that I don't believe in
coincidences
and I think too many weird things have
happened in my life and
I think if I didn't have faith my dad I
didn't he wasn't an overtly religious
man but he his faith in God really
depends when he was in prison and at the
end of his life we really started
talking about God any afterlife a lot
and I found that his interpretation of
it is the same as mine and I think it
makes every it makes pain easier to
handle it makes surrendering to the
things you can't control a lot easier
but there was a period of time where I
was like God I ain't gonna have to have
some conversations but I don't know I
don't know how you get through every day
without having some foundation of faith
like it I don't know what and it's no
judgments everybody lives their own way
but if you believe in nothing like I
don't think I could get up every morning
and do anything if I didn't believe that
there was a higher purpose and a higher
calling and that I won't get to see my
dad at some point on the other side so
in one second I have one final question
for Megan McCain is the most social
final question I have ever asked to a
guest okay it is a very very crucial
question and that is can you please get
me on the view but if you want a scare
or Meghan McCain Jensen you have to be a
daily water subscriber to subscribe head
on over to daily we're calm click
Subscribe and watch the rest of our
conversation there Meghan McCain thank
you so much for stopping by this been a
pleasure I really appreciate it and I
look forward to other you're gonna get
good talking to me and I'm gonna get for
talking to you perfect so we don't care
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is
directed by Mathis Glover and produced
by Jonathan hey executive producer
Jeremy Boren associate producer Colton
Haas our guests are booked by Kaitlyn
Manor post-production is supervised by
Alex zingara editing by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Purnima hair and
makeup is by Jesuit alvera title
graphics by Cynthia Angulo the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20